[Musique]
d'un livre essentiel pour comprendre
pendant ces années 60 je ne dis pas pour
l'éternité le monde où nous sommes et
nous avons choisi de vivre
j'ajouterai que les choses est un livre
drôle très bien écrit et dont voici
l'auteur georges perec 1 m 65
une trentaine encore un peu et
étudiantes franchement je ne m'y
attendais pas au ton ironique et mordant
du livre correspondait dans mon esprit à
un vieux monsieur pensif un professeur
par exemple on peut se tromper vous
voyez alors commençons qui êtes vous
georges perec et bien j'ai 30 ans
effectivement je suis documentaliste le
laboratoire de recherche médicale c'est
à dire que je reçois des articles en
anglais en italien
je fais des fiches j'élabore tout un
système de bibliographie qui servent à
la recherche
c'est un travail que je fais depuis
quatre ans qui me prend la plupart de
mes journées
mais je parle parvient à réserver
quelques heures en fin d'après midi ou
le soir pour écrire je suis marié depuis
cinq ans je n'ai pas d'enfant et quand
je ne perds pas mon temps au cinéma ou
dans des cafés j'essaye de créer
j'écris le but dix ans j'ai écrit
plusieurs nouvelles quatre ou cinq
romans qui sont tous restés inédits et
j'ai commencé les choses il ya trois ans
je vis ici enfin ce livre correspond à
une certaine expérience de
l'installation que j'ai fait je vis ici
depuis à peu près cinq ans à côté de la
mosquée de paris
dans un appartement assez petit et mon
livre d'une certaine manière reprend
tous les éléments de ma propre
expérience
c'est vrai près de la mosquée de paris
j'ai retrouvé la rue quatrefages le
grand arbre le vieil immeuble qui sont
le cadre de la vie de perec et aussi
celui de son livre voici la petite pièce
où travaillent pérec
mais il travaille aussi dans le livre
son héros jérôme et la photo de madame
perec qui pourrait être celle de
l'héroïne de sylvie il faudra demander à
jérôme je veux dire à perec s'il s'agit
d'une autobiographie mais voici d'autres
détails
la très belle carte ancienne le tableau
d'antonello de messine les livres voilà
le décor mais que font les deux héros
jérôme et sylvie un curieux métier en
vérité celui de sondeurs d'opinion
en voici une démonstration par une jeune
enquêtrice c'est le terme qui pourrait
être là sylvie du livre les questions
sont tirés de la page 28 des choses est
ce que vous êtes pour ou contre les
transports en commun vous voulez n'est
ce pas fait de la chicorée
est-ce que vous pouvez mieux ce que vous
pensez de la jeunesse pouvez vous nous
dire ce que vous pensez des aspirateurs
traîneaux ce que vous pouvez mieux ce
que vous pensez des machines à laver et
madame tu aimes la peur est toute faite
est ce que vous allez me dire quelle
qualité google
un matelas j'ai pris ce métier parce que
c'est finalement c'est un des ces
métiers où il est le plus facile de
gagner de l'argent assez facilement
c'est jamais très bien payés parce qu'on
est finalement toujours exploitée par
ceux qui vous emploie mais où on gagne
quand même assez vite et assez
régulièrement ce qui fait qu'on a
toujours l'impression d'être en vacances
on prend le train on va en province
trois jours et puis on revient et puis
et puis on a gagné 30 mille francs et
puis après on n'a pas de travail pendant
huit jours et on dépense conduit le
franc et on se croit on se croit libre
alors ils ont choisi une vie un peu
bohème mais enfin c'est tout de même un
monde particulier je veux dire oui c'est
exactement le particulier où il y a
d'ailleurs une espèce de de loin enfin
une espèce d'institutions parce que le
problème quand on canton et boën quand
on élimine quand on travaille assez peu
quand on n'a pas d'argent c'est de faire
semblant enfin d'utiliser tous les
moyens qui vous permettent de faire
semblant d'avoir de l'argent par exemple
on a envie de deux chemises l'américaine
avec des cols boutonnant inconnus comme
ça se portent beaucoup maintenant comme
ça se portait d'ailleurs un peu au
moment j'ai écrit mon livre et c'était
popularisé par les comédies américaines
elle viendrait les acheter aux puces ne
s'achète pas boulevard saint-germain
pascal 7000 francs mais on les achète
opus parce qu'elles valent quand se
feront enfin 15 cents francs pour les
mavs la même chose enfin on a envie
d'aimables que l'on voit chez des
antiquaires
mais on achète des tables humain peut
vraiment opus enfin et c'est il ya tout
un espèce de système de compensation
mais ce système une débouche sur rien
enfin si on se retrouve toujours coincé
un certainement avant ce qui me semblait
nécessaire de décrire c'est cette
impression que mes personnages ont
d'être complètement bloqué afin d'être
être un certain moment d'être arrêté de
neu neu neu ils n'en peuvent plus il ya
trop de choses qui valent ils veulent la
perf voudrais simplement veulent être
heureux d'une manière très simple ils
veulent
il va l'être ray comme des petits
enfants candidats afin de faire et il se
pose la question du bonheur et pour eux
le bonheur c'est tout ce que enfin leur
esprit est complètement imprégné de
toutes les images de tout le vocabulaire
du bonheur qui n'est pas leur
vocabulaire qui elle afin qu'ils aient
leur vocabulaire mais qui leur est
donnée par l'est par les journaux par
par l'express par par le magazine mais
c'est un don dont le trailer c'est un
monde particulier de voir ce que c'est
pas un problème complètement général
lasser si vous voulez ça c'est là la
surprise parce que quand j'ai écrit ce
livre je pensais précisément ont d'abord
à les problèmes que j'avais fréquemment
évoquée auquel j'ai souvent pensé
et puis je pensais à mes amis enfin puis
j'ai pensé à un groupe un peu plus large
de l'étudiant d'étudiants qui continue
qui essayent de continuer et puis j'ai
pensé aux cinéphiles par exemple enfin à
des groupes de gens comme ça
m'enfin ça faisait quelques quelques
centaines de personnes à paris peut-être
enfin de ton quelques milliers vie j'ai
une impression c'est surtout d'après ce
que j'ai ce que j'ai lu ne va pas ce
qu'on a écrit son livre que beaucoup
plus de gens se reconnaissaient et ça il
me semble que c'est que c'est lié au
vocabulaire que ceux employés dans mon
livre que c'est lié au travail que j'ai
fait sur le sou sur l'écriture c'est à
dire que j'ai employé un langage
j'ai utilisé un langage qui parle
beaucoup de gens qui parlaient beaucoup
de gens parce que c'est simplement le
langage de la publicité
nous vivons dans un monde qui est beau
qui nous parle d'une manière très forte
la beauté d'une ouverture d'un meuble
nous sentons tout de suite qu'elle
contient beaucoup plus de choses que la
simple beauté
il nous semble qu'elle détient une sorte
de secret qu'elle nous offre un
véritable art de vivre que tout ce qui
nous est donné à voir c'est beaucoup
plus de choses que la beauté c'est de
l'argent c'est du confort d'une bonne
heure ce presque une certaine forme
idéale les voitures luisantes les
meubles étincelant des espaces immenses
et claire
les moquettes le monde dans lequel nous
vivons on demande que nous rencontrons
chaque fois que nous sortons dans la rue
chaque fois que nous entrons un magasin
est un monde riche fascinant et beau
l'ennui c'est que nous pouvons voir nous
n'avons pas le droit de toucher parce
qu'en fait nous ne vivons pas
l'enseignement nous ne conduisons pas
ces voitures ne mangeons pas du foie
gras du homard nos repas ne vivons pas
dans les espaces clairs couvert de
moquette
cette différence face ce qui cette
différence entre ce que nous pouvons
rêver ce que nous donne à rêver
ce que nous nous sommes donnés comme
rêve et la réalité beaucoup plus
mesquine et rétréci de notre vie c'est à
dire nos appartement encombré nouvelle
scène trajets en métro
cette différence est à la base de ce que
veut et de ce que cherche le publicité
dans la société que l'on appelle société
de consommation essentielle être
consommée et tout nous pousse à
consommer mais les déceptions les
frustrations qui accompagne cette quête
du bonheur que nous avons confondu trop
vite avec le confort avec la richesse
cette déception constituent une part
très importante la publicité des
étalages de vitrine une certaine manière
nous rendent fous nous saoulent toutes
ces choses ne sont là que pour
entretenir une espèce de frénésie de
vertige d'hypnose toute la question que
pose mon livre c'est que faire en face
de ce vertige
je ne crois pas que mon livre répondait
je ne crois pas que la réponse
appartiennent la littérature mais il m'a
semblé important est nécessaire de poser
cette question et de décrire ce vertige
[Musique]
vous avez écrit georges perec dans w mon
projet d'écrire mon histoire ses formes
est presque en même temps que mon projet
d'écrire et cette histoire
elle commence je crois à belleville dans
cette ville que vous avez décrit fait la
rue maintenant
mais plus qu'un vague souvenir de rue
c'est une rick est en train de mourir
depuis des années est fait
c'est des vagues et
la maison ma mère avait son son petit
magasin n'a pas plu est resté est encore
resté deux techniques ou de cette mesure
là
c'est très bon mais déjà fait la
couverture de ces laps de temps choisi
ça fait bizarre inégale de je vais dans
dans cette rue pour essayer de la
décrire de seuil et de retrouver les
ministres me rattache est ce que vous
avez vécu avant la guerre comme jusqu'à
42 et que je n'ai pas revu ensuite
pendant des années et des années à venir
a découvert 38 ans je crois vers une
seconde seulement et j'ai mis beaucoup
de temps même avant de retrouver de me
rendre compte que c'était précisément
cette maison et 7,7 porte c'est peu et
pour moi c'est le fait est le point de
départ de toute fin de match native
autobiographique qui était qu'ils
étaient en forme au début c'est à dire
quand je dis que mon mon projet d'écrire
que c'était d'abord le projet d'écrire
mon histoire mais j'ai mis très
longtemps avant de ramener à faire
savoir julie raconte ça tient cette
génération
votre écriture très vite et a fait sauce
de votre vie des sources un peu oublié
parce que la guerre ça a été le service
en confirmité je ne cèderai lier ça
aussi je veux dire avant de me de
l'assumer
avant d'assumer moi mon histoire comme
tel pouvant gens la possibilité de dire
jodoin et
que dire de considérer comme d'arriver à
cerner quelque chose qui soit ma propre
histoire
mon propre espace mon propre lieu
précisément parce que les ces lieux ne
me semblait qu'il n'existe pas j'aime
beaucoup de temps disons à incorporer à
me sentir de niveau appartenant à s'être
assagi à ce quartier est à cette époque
qu est ce que ceux ci on comptera des
relectures que vous et réinsérer est-ce
que vous la préférez l'écriture elle
quelque chose qui a traversé ce cet
espace qui qui maintenant est en tout
cas habiter dans mon souvenir l'image du
cul je me sers factuellement dans le
livre que j'ai en préparation c'est
sombre
c'est le point central ces histoires de
d'un homme qui résout des pulls des
nonnes qui les fabriquent
et c'est aussi lisse et le livre entier
et est fait quand même plus de 20 est
construit comme un pluton chaque
chapitre serait une pièce
ce fut le point de départ du livre c'est
une maison c'est la description d'une
maison mais une petite maison une bonne
comme grands immeubles
voilà donc un des premiers modèles des
premiers exemples du dé ce qui m'a amené
les moins à composer organisé cette
semaine une maison on veut aller toutes
ces complications et avec
et les pièces oui avec une profondeur
apparente qui est donnée par le fait que
ces pièces ouvre sur d'autres pièces 9
carats oui et puis des scènes se passent
non non on voit d'où ils vous voient
tous et l'année sur une sorte de tableau
qu'un peintre comme s'il n'ya pas être
vous verrez un peintre qui reste de
peindre ce tableau où il y aurait 7 cet
immeuble ouvert et il y aurait tout
c'est toutes ces pièces toutes ces
petites cases et alors on décrit ce qui
ce se qui se passe dans ces pièces voilà
le la maison a là un autre plan de la
maison est là on sait qu'ici il ya une
chambre dans lequel vivent les femmes
ici nous sommes bien étudiants ici une
étudiante ici vit dans une petite
chambre peintre qui a pas tout l'art
toute la maison et qui ce qui s'est
représenté dans son coin comme dans le
tableau du moyen-âge ici il ya une pièce
qui était occupé par le monsieur qui
fabriquait les puces ici un grand
appartement occupé par le monsieur qui
résout les puces en fait on s'apercevra
que toute l'histoire et que l'histoire
de ces deux personnages de nos relations
mais ça on ne saura beaucoup plus tard
on voit là une autre représentation
ça c'est comment va se déplacer dans
cette maison c'est à dire que ça aurait
donné l'ordre du chapitre enfin c'est
uniquement du lecteur va céder
classement le lecteur les domaines moi
même un train à travers différentes
pièces de les décrire chaque fois je me
l'écrire ici on est dans l'escalier
entre deux autres le quatrième et
cinquième étages et une dame qui est
notre ami noté qu'ils se dirigent vers
l'appartement en ce qu'elle fait ici on
rentre dans jama partout moi puis lancez
vous revenez jamais on ne revient jamais
on revient dans les pièces qui
appartiennent au même appartement mais
jamais dans le monde ne parcourt le
chemin qu une seule fois et c'est
seulement dans les dernières passes du
livre que on aura cette espèce d'image
complète qui expliquera
un peu pourquoi le livre a été écrit ce
qu'il représente pour moi qui expliquera
son titre
[Musique]